le 3 mai il est prévu que les
restrictions de déplacements et donc
effectivement l'attestation
l'interdiction des déplacements inter
régionaux soient levés et que à la mi
mai certaines terrasses certains lieux
de culture rouvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya aujourd'hui légèrement moins deux
patients hospitalisés très légèrement
moins deux patients hospitalisés que la
semaine dernière et le nombre de
personnes en réanimation tend à se
stabiliser
il apparaît que nous pourrions être au
pic ou proches de l'être
l'épidémie recule deux fois moins
rapidement qu'en novembre la pression
hospitalière est extrêmement forte
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un pic la part des
démissions canton un pigment c'est ce
cas derrière
oui là actuellement on ne sait pas ce
cas derrière est rien et quand on voit
les courbes de la deuxième vague
on sait très bien qu'on n'a pas fait
depuis qu'il est évident que si jamais
les conséquences de ce confinement
troisième manière que l'on vit ne
donnent pas les résultats sur le freine
pas l'épidémie autant prix globaux
autant que celle il est nécessaire alors
on n'aura pas d'autre choix que de
monter encore en grade en puissance dans
les mesures de confinement